[Music]
so guys I'm here today with John Tracy
who has been a part of D for many years
over 20 in fact he was one of our boiler
maker welders so we're going to have a
little chat to him today about his
experience with delate over the years
thank you for joining me joh you're
welcome um first of all I guess do you
want to tell us a little bit about
yourself where you're originally from
and a bit about your life
story well I was originally a farmer at
chudley and then we eventually sold that
farm and I moved into
delone in 1983 I think it was you I was
probably there for 2 years and David
Cunningham came to see me about the
worlding were you qualified or ini
qualified I used to do welding on the
farm and yes I enjoyed it my ambition
was my next world will be better than my
last it's a good ambition to have yeah
and over your span of sort of that 20
years did you see a lot of change within
D
Mage yes and the Machinery was getting
bigger and better and was most of your
sort of your building work was it
building new Machinery most of the time
or new Machinery yes I don't think I
ever did a repair
first big roller we built was that big
and heavy that we had to put a the
friction brake okay under the bra to
stop it from pushing you down Hills
which I think it weighed when it was
filled with water it weighed about 9
tons and was there a particular piece of
Machinery that you particularly like to
work on something that you were extra
proud of at all or I guess rollers if I
made $200 off yeah 200 wow what is it do
you think that sets them apart within
the industry you know they've got a
pretty good reputation is there
something the quality of the Machinery
yeah yes it have to be speaks for itself
really doesn't it well it does
yeah I think nearly every phone R T's
got a
roller and as far as um you know working
as a bower maker welder do you have any
advice for anybody that is considering
it as a career choice or that's a very
good career choice and uh make sure when
they're doing all these things that they
have the the proper safety gear and
breathing apparatus and all that sort of
thing yeah yeah that's right definitely
rewarding when you can see implements
like this you know out in the padic many
many years after you've built them isn't
it and when you drive around the state
you see blue and yellow and when you
think about the fact that it's 50 years
this year for dmate it is yep how does
it sort of make you feel like is it do
you feel a sense of pride of being a
part of that or oh yes well definitely
[Music]